[Music]
the merger between City and travelers is
one of the worst big bag mergers in
history City group was the collection of
dozens of businesses and so there had
been issues with compliance and risk
management the thing you have to realize
is the the merger that Sandy W and John
Reed come up with it was illegal if you
look at simply its share price
performance City Bank has trailed its
other big American Rivals since the
merger 25 years ago the stock is down
over 80% welcome to the banking business
where you have a crisis around every
[Music]
corner time and again you've seen
problems or scandals or trading losses
erupt in different corners of the bank
that have taken the senior managements
by surprise city is by no means the only
bank that has had to pay fines for risk
issues money laundering issues
compliance issues but the bigger a bank
gets the more complex it gets the more
Global it gets the more challenges like
this that they have to come up against
we've seen City Bank have problems with
money laundering in different
departments again which the Senior
Management didn't know about in the case
of bamax if there are problems that come
up you have to ask yourself if they were
paying good enough attention if their
systems were focused on the right thing
more recently there have been big
problems in this it sector where
essentially systems have broken down and
the bank has made payments by accident
to clients time and again we see the
same pattern yes we are back to thinking
about City and this um nearly $1 billion
mistaken payment that they made so what
really starts the latest chapter of City
struggles it's something that's pretty
basic City just needs to make a payment
of around $9 million to a group of
creditors to the Cosmetics company
Revlon but instead of transferring $9
million they accidentally transfer $900
million 99% of people don't pay
attention to this we just see headlines
about money moving and transactions in
fact the the plumbing of the financial
system is extremely complicated banks
are doing millions of transactions a day
uh
99.999% of the time it works out okay
what's unique about this case is one
obviously it involves a lot of money
$900 million
two it's this quirky situation where
some of the firms that got repaid
accidentally had a grievance with City
group and had a reason not to give the
money back most of those creditors a
group of hedge funds pay city that money
back they recognize oh this was made an
error but a group of those hedge funds
think actually you've paid us this money
there's no obligation for us to pay it
back we're going to keep it and so city
is then in this long protracted fight
over around $500 million trying to get
that money back that they accidentally
transferred in addition to that
Regulators investors are asking the
question how can this happen
the Revlon issue at City uh was due to
human error according to the company uh
but it really reflects underlying deeper
problems it was a microcosm of a larger
issue of antiquated
technology I mean for all the progress
city has made in the front office with
digitization for consumers the back
office needs enormous modernization
remember the flash crash of European
stocks last One turns out it might have
been caused by a London City Bank
staffers in 2022 almost 2 years after
the Revlon case there's another issue
with City they cause what's called a
flash crash a sudden drop in a number of
European stocks because of a fat finger
trading error uh one of their Traders
sent through a much larger order of
stocks than planned this really moved
markets in a significant way and again
these sort of things they do happen
occasionally but they shouldn't happen
and it just showed how the problems that
City had has they can't be fixed
overnight and if you look at simply its
share price performance what is very
clear is in the last few years City Bank
has trailed its other big American
Rivals and even now in
2023 is trading below its projected Book
value which is quite remarkable the
problem at City group is simply the
complexity and so you know it really
stretches back to the the mergers that
they pursued I'll tell you city has it
all I mean when this merger was
announced in 1998 it was the Paradigm of
capitalism this is where the future was
headed for the next 50 years in
hindsight the city Travelers deal
created a lot of
angst when City Bank did its famous
merger in 1998 it really became a symbol
of the changing American regulatory
landscape and the changing Ambitions of
americ American Banks the '90s really
was a time of growth on Wall Street and
just in the economy more broadly it was
a time of burining opportunity the
markets were good National mood was
pretty positive interest rates were low
people felt like they were on the cusp
of this great globalization wave you had
booming emerging markets in Latin
America in Asia and really felt like the
financial world was going to become more
interconnected the whole period in the
80s and 90s came came at a time when
lots of companies were combining in lots
of different areas Financial Services
was actually kind of late to the party
because there were rules against
particular types of murgers that was the
time when people were talking about
creating Financial supermarkets um
buying everything from the same company
uh whatever your financial need and city
was the first one to uh to give that a
shot the idea was that if you created
big Champions they would do better and
you know they would have more profits
while also be able to cut costs
Financial Services to a certain extent
trailed behind even though the bankers
themselves were working on these big
murger
deals you had on the one hand City that
had a huge business around the globe
known to be an innovator in technology
and credit card it has its roots back to
the beginning of the American Enterprise
very traditional US Bank the largest the
highest rated what is today's City Group
started all the way back in 1812 as
First National City Bank in New York and
decades later it became one of the real
Pioneers in US banking in going overseas
in Latin America and Asia globally
around the world in the late 90s in 1974
it's rebranded as City Corp and then in
1993 it hits another Milestone it
becomes the biggest bank holding company
in the world this isn't just a New York
Bank anymore City Corp at that point was
a a giant bank that did corporate and
Retail banking Travelers meanwhile was
an insurance company that also had an
investment banking arm Smith Barney they
make money the oldfashioned way Solomon
Smith Barney which Al did wealth
management as well so it brought the
whole giant panoply of pretty much
everything you can do in Financial
Services Under One Roof John Reed was
the CEO of City uh he had come up
through the consumer side of the bank
on the traveler side we had Sandy W who
um had built up uh broker dealers he's
from Benson Hurst Brooklyn he's
different he looks different than what
you'd expect for a CEO and he saw the
world
differently the merger they're proposing
is illegal most Bankers wouldn't go
there but it took someone who was had a
different V vision and they decided well
we'll do the merger first and the
world's going to change for us and and
they were
[Music]
right in 2001 the share price almost hit
$600 a share cheered on by investors the
merger between City and travelers it's a
really seminal moment in US Finance
because it's the merger that triggers
the repeal of glass deagle act which had
post us depression piece of legislation
had been in place since the 1930s
basically to try to Dr risk US Banks to
separate Commercial Banking activities
from riskier Investment Banking
activities when they announced the
merger it was not yet legal for all of
these things to be Under One Roof but
the Clinton administration had made
clear that they wanted to relax the
regulations and it was pretty clear that
Congress was going to go along so there
was a general agreement that they were
going to change this and by having an
actual deal it meant that Congress had a
deadline to act I mean in a way it
almost forced congress's hand is that
that they had had been talking about it
and now they had a deal that if they
didn't pass new new rules then this deal
would collapse and it was this giant
successful deal and was supposed to be
fantastic for the stock markets City
Bank became the first big American
Juggernaut to try and combine Investment
Banking and Retail Banking and it did so
in a very dramatic fashion and it made
it very clear that it wanted to be a
One-Stop shopping Enterprise it went on
a spending spree gobbling up all kinds
of operations and essentially planting
Flags in many many countries the one I
know best is Japan where Essen City Bank
became one of the first groups that
really had a significant presence in the
Japanese Market one of the things that
changed when City merged with Travelers
was that Travelers was willing to take
partial ownership of entities and city
had never done that before so for
example they owned part of Bank hlvy in
Poland they had ownership interest in a
bank in Turkey whereas previously when
City made a bank acquisition they would
acquire 100% And I think that probably
contributed to uh some of the issues
that have happened on the road the
enormity of it and the the difficulty of
running all these various businesses
different traditional segments the old
the the old school Bankers with the Risk
Takers and the client focused people the
broker that was going to talk to the
grandmother who had savings and try to
invest it I mean these different
cultures never really mixed and so
pretty quickly Sandy wild the ultimate
operator uh who had one out in the
merger and got rid of his rival John
Reed to take over this all Isles of
Finance he can't make it work and by
2003 and 2004 Sandy wild he's
[Music]
out turned out that insurance at least
in America doesn't sit all that well
with banking this is not true globally
if you if you look across the Atlantic
the big French banks are what are known
as Bank Assurance Banks and they have
found a great way I mean they make money
hand over fist doing it their way but in
the US for whatever reason insurance and
banking do not grow together very well
so Travelers decided relatively or City
Group which was the combin decided
relatively quickly that they were not
they were getting good profits off
Travelers and it so they split that part
off this idea of a financial Supermarket
with Consumer Finance banking Insurance
all kinds of products you know just
build it and they will come that was a
fail then you had a failed strategy they
layered mergers on top of mergers and
never integrated them you had failed
execution when it wasn't working well
they took extra risk city has had a big
problem with silos in the last couple of
decades in the sense that it's so big
and complex that it's almost impossible
for the management to know everything
that's happening across a bank and so
when the subprime morgage crisis erupted
City Bank was suddenly left with a very
nasty headache and problem which the
Senior Management appears to have had no
idea was a potential risk Chuck Prince
Charles Prince he made a very famous
quote I believe to the financial times
just before the crisis about uh having
to participate in financial markets and
transactions even though things were
getting difficult people were worried
there was still this pressure to to
participate in in Risky activities again
he described it as dancing while the
music is still playing a quote that's
still uh still resonates
today in recent years Innovative
mortgage products have helped millions
of Americans afford their own homes and
that's good
unfortunately some of these products
were used irresponsibly so we get to
20072 2008 the financial crisis Hits
Huge moment uh on Wall Street and City
group is not spared in fact it's one of
the the firms that's hit the hardest it
has all sorts of toxic assets on its
balance sheet you could have seen it
coming right if there was a risky
Venture that was the point of City Group
the point of City group was to get money
from lower return businesses into higher
return businesses and the businesses
that have the highest returns are always
the riskiest and the riskiest business
to be in was subprime mortgage so City
ran right into it 24 hours ago the boss
of the world's biggest bank City Group
fell on his sword after revealing
another 5 billion of bad loans in
America's housing market it was hit so
hard uh by the crisis and it took all
this government money it was uh really
Shackled for many many years there was
years of unwinding its balance sheet
paying fines structurally city was going
to have a harder time because you know
it had a lot of pieces in a lot of
different countries for example JP
Morgan in fact didn't have a particular
particular big International footprint
it stuff is mostly concentrated in the
US and the UK so it doesn't have Capital
popped all over the place so in that
world city is fighting against the tide
and so it's having to reinvent itself
and it's really hard a glass ceiling has
been shattered in finance City Group
president Jane Fraser will soon become
the first woman to head a big Wall
Street Bank City group named her
Thursday to succeed Michael Corbat when
he retires in February
[Music]
City never really has a rethink vicam
pandant who takes over for City he's
also from the Wall Street side of the
business he sort of has a a similar
profile to Sandy wild and probably looks
at the world in the same place the
person who takes over from him uh
Michael Corbett he also he's a Solomon
Brothers person so he's also of this
kind of Wall Street merger risk-taking
now to look forward is is in a way Jane
she doesn't come from the dominant
culture on Wall Street the investment
bankers and and the the merger types
everybody who's run City basically since
the 2008 crisis has been trying to
simplify and clean up and rationalized
City and they've tried different ways
and Jane Fraser is no exception she has
tried to trim back the bits that are not
profitable and she has tried to focus
City on the things it does well so that
it can be profitable without wasting
money she has struggled to make that
work um I think anybody would struggle
to make that work in fact her
predecessors definitely struggled
there's a cynical view sometimes
expressed on Wall Street which is that
when a big company gives a top job to a
woman it's often because a company's in
trouble and I'd love to think that
wasn't the case but certainly when it
comes to City having given the top job
to Jane Fraser it does does raise a
question about whether once again a
woman's coming in as a troubleshooter
Jane Frasier uh was a Management
Consultant earlier uh in her career and
has uh been at City group for uh for
many many years and respected executive
she's in the uh early early part of her
tenure and so her challenge uh really is
that again now that we're like 10 years
on from the financial crisis uh City
group is as clean and streamlined uh as
it has been in a long time uh can it now
actually start to grow can it take
market share it valuation improve it is
its valuation multiples Trail uh many of
its peers and can they turn the corner
on on this narrative that the firm is
too big and too complex and not well-run
it helps that she is an unflashy UNF
flamboyant person who doesn't often grab
headlines and that's very much in tune
with the mood and Zeitgeist in banking
today because whereas you used to have
these Rockstar bankers and financiers a
couple of decades ago
which would basically grab the headlines
and lots of attention today it's very
clear that investors want their banking
leaders to be essentially understated if
not almost shy and focused on sober
unglamorous parts of Finance rather than
trying to gamble or do profitable um
hedge fund trading or things like that
so in that sense Jane Fraser is very
much suited to the times but it remains
to be clear whether she can convince
investors that she really has a new
Mission and new strategy for City Bank
her current plan which she just
announced which is the most sweeping um
reorganization in 15 years is to bust
down the silos I would say the city was
divided in divisions and each division
had a specific operational manager and
she was on top and that would have been
true for the previous CEO as well she
has decided to get rid of that layer of
management and have six different
operational businesses that directly
report to her it's an interesting
strategy um it's risky it it very much
means that she is personally responsible
for the operational decisions they make
there's no she has no insulation if
something terrible happens it's her um
which may be great if she if she turns
out to be a really good manager and and
really good at making choices and and
freeing up each of these businesses to
do their best it could be very good if
it doesn't go well there isn't anyone
else to
blame
when the merger was done it really was a
time of more is more for banks whereas
now with City less is more for these
guys they really need to refocus the
business and um be and show itself that
it can be really profitable at what it
does instead of trying to be old things
to old people JP Morgan Chase uh Jamie
diamonds figured out how to be a bank to
everyone Bank of America has also uh
merged investment banking with
traditional banking so I I think it's
wrong to say that that Sandy W's Vision
um failed but it certainly um failed at
City Group this entire industry has
become more humble and City Group when
it was created was not uh an exercise in
humility uh it was an exercise and uh
arrogance and we live in an era of
humble banking uh and City group is
going to have to figure out how it fits
into that new
[Music]
world